I still think on that creature from the
abyss that preyed upon me my faculties
were far from lucid but I quite clearly
sensed certain emotions a wrenching
nostalgia a lost joy an object of
obsession and a sincere hope to reclaim
it could these thoughts belong to the
beast from the abyss but if that were
true then perhaps it is no beast after
all Four Queens remain in empty kingdoms
all of them fragments of this creature
that was vanquished long ago we have
seen examples of their evil in what
remains one stands alone in the ruins of
her home another rose from the ashes of
a lost Kingdom and yet another gained
the love of her King and used it to
force him into a dark corner where he
would forever think on his mistakes but
you will hear the tale of a fourth Queen
before the end of this story and she
will make you question everything that
you have previously held true alsanna
queen of the ivory King also stands
alone in an empty Kingdom this dead
go back do not know why do we build
walls there are two reasons the first is
more common it's to protect something
precious but the second is much more
rare and much more terrifying it's to
keep something from getting out the
walls of a lamb loose are those second
kind of walls the city is a Pandora's
Box built to contain one of the most
ancient evils the world ever knew the
chaos the chaos did not always exist it
was born of fear and desperation long
ago in the age of Lords theirs was the
earliest civilization built upon the
first flame ever to be four powerful
beings derived their strength from this
flame for it gave them souls one soul of
Dark One of Light a soul of death and
isola of life inevitably this first
flame began to dwindle and so too did
the lords the witch of izalith with
great power of a flame thought to focus
the power of her life soul to create a
new flame a second flame that could
replace the first so that their age
would not end so the witch and her
daughter's initiated this ritual but
something went wrong the flame she
created was too powerful and she failed
to control it this was the birth of
chaos the witch and her sisters were
either killed or malformed and the witch
herself became the bed of all chaos
deep below izalith a city lost to the
twisted flame countless demons spewed
forth from the inextinguishable chaos
infesting izalith until the land was
overrun lifetimes later the bed of chaos
would be defeated but not destroyed and
after the rise and fall of many
civilizations the chaos rose again in
the country of furrow sir
on a barren plain where a lay invoice
was to be built the four osan's were the
ones who dealt with the chaos for it had
erupted on their land for awesomes are
famed for their God of War valuing valor
and
on that prowess notable men of Rosa were
shield lessly thyine who grew tired of
the frailty of human foes and set off to
slay dragons there was van gaal the mad
beast of the battlefield who claimed the
heads of countless enemies and there
were the frozen lion Knights feared for
their nimble two-handed sword play but
the highest-ranking knight and the most
famed of them all was the ivory king of
rasa after taking his crown they say who
was the first to swing his sword in
times of need be it for his homeland for
his people and his sword was required
far to the north for the old chaos had
resurfaced there once more this land is
barren cursed by the old chaos it gave
birth to atrocities and the people fled
in fear here until him Oh Lord the ivory
came he came with his sword his soul and
his lost Knights the ivory King fought
back the chaos when it was contained
they built a lay employs a vast rampart
city golems patrolled the walls given
life by the ivory King they were charged
with the containment of the creatures of
the chaos within a cult of priestesses
was formed who devoted themselves to a
ritual that appears to the ancient flame
the king himself erected his throne at
the very entrance to chaos for he wished
to serve as the first line of defense
any creature of chaos that threatened
his city would have to pass him first
and the King would not falter it was
here in la emploice that the ivory King
took a queen alsanna it appears she was
a woman of great power for she possessed
the same talent as the priestesses did
and she quelled the chaos flame below
together in a city cut off from the rest
of the world and facing constant peril
they were Wed and they stood together
despite the hardship like the other
Queens before her Isana was born of dark
she Wed her king out of selfishness for
she saw that the king of Rosa was strong
and intended to find safety by his side
nevertheless the ivory King loved her
and supported this child of the abyss
even as he fought against the flames of
chaos two ancient evils weighed upon the
king one in front of him and one at his
side but even so he weathered them both
for himself and for his people there is
evidence that having a child of dark by
his side weighed upon the king he had
seven pets and two I found in the
outskirts of eleum loyce tasked with the
mercy killings of those who were exiled
from the city Lud and zahlen are great
cats brothers of Arva a tiger that
remains in the city itself the two
outside are cursed with a dark aura and
one has to wonder whether they became
this way due to the presence of our
sauna for they are kept out of sight
when none would report on their true
nature or what the child of dark was
doing to those who stood beside her
inevitably there came a moment where the
ivory King sense the degradation of his
own soul in this moment he made a
decision he would not run from chaos
rather he would give himself to chaos in
order to appease the flame without a
word he left his home he left his wife
and he left his country but not without
one final act for before he set off to
strike at the heart of chaos he
entrusted everything to alsanna upon his
parting he handed her alayhim voice the
city and a ceremonial blade by its
namesake the twin blades of eleum loyce
one light and one dark were entwined as
the ivory king and his dark queen once
were he knew Isana was a child of dark
all along but he said nothing he
believed her to be more than the sum of
her parts and so she was the king's
belief in the Queen allowed her to rise
above her dark nature it was his final
gift to her
but then he left never to return
inevitably debate the king was gravely
figure figure and plunged into the chaos
his past the lair lorises was frozen in
tight hide its leader loss loss loss I
remain here here to contend with details
hovering my always wishes though I am
yet to know your name stranger will you
lend me your stress dressed I have but
one wish wish that my dear Lord would
might be freed from that him speaks with
many overlay analysis faithful knights
followed their Lord into the chaos the
kingdom he dutiful subjects waited
patiently for his homecoming coming but
it was to no more weight to bear the
night is reborn will follow your word
the path hunter Caleb's is now
and please do all you can chaos claimed
the ivory King and many nights of Loyce
many were burned along with their Lord
and to this day they burn in agony
alongside their once proud king lacking
all sense of self and driven only to
expunge those who might disturb the
flame even former compatriots but those
who survived fight with us now commanded
to strike down their former comrades and
their own King the sacrifice is total
and they freeze the portals so that we
may face Chaos's new champion what makes
a king some say that it is birthright
while others call it destiny
perhaps it is not important as long as
the King's name serves to unite his
people the ivory king was the greatest
King we have seen so far his sacrifice
saved the world from chaos and he was
not changed by the child of dark at his
side in fact she alone remains despite
her fearful nature and watches over
chaos out of respect for her Lord
such was his influence over her for
alsanna
we free the ivory Kings soul from the
grip of chaos you've grabbed aunt and I
wish my dear Lord is departed no I have
no regrets
I was the mix of the dark long ago in
the depths of the earth races my father
perish
the dark is shattered into tiny pieces
one of which was how frightened I was
afraid I was born but a splitter loved
after I felt that I might might simply
disappear I am in fact the incarnation
of my father's fears yes I saw that the
King be this last was strong I sought
him and him to sustain myself to smother
my fears now I realize that he may have
known more long gong-gong I was born of
fear and my Lord provided comfort and so
here I remain arrestor my Lord's wishes
watching over chaos until the end of
time
my father once healing succumb to the
doctor and later set his ocean is raging
advance
the darkness guided by its first four
sources but paralysis man is no
different